NIKHIL SRIVASTAVA: So,
welcome, everybody,
to the afternoon session.
I'm Nikhil Srivastava.
I'm a senior scientist here.
Research fellows, our postdocs,
and earlier career faculty
who we host here
at the Institute,
either for a semester as
part one of our programs,
or for a longer period, as
part of our machine learning
pod or our quantum pod.
And they're really an integral
part of life at the Institute,
accounting for a lot of
the energy, excitement,
and discoveries which
take place here.
So we have about 40
fellows at the moment.
And we're lucky to hear from
nine of them in this session.
And so, speakers, you have
five minutes for your talk.
And we're on a bit
of a tight schedule.
I'll show you this one-minute
when there's one minute left.
And there are two
options for mics.
If you want to use the
handheld mic, feel free.
If you want the clip
mic, then [? Omeed ?]
will help you with that.
So let's start with--
we have Sorrachai
from the algorithms--
from the data structures
and optimization program.
SORRACHAI
YINGCHAREONTHAWORNCHAI: OK,
thank you for the introduction.
So this first lightning talk
is about vertex connectivity
in poly-logarithmic max-flows.
This is joint work with
Jason Lee, Danupon Nanongkai,
Debmalya Panigrahi, and
Thatchaphol Saranurak.
I want to spend for
three to four minutes
to explain why this is
an interesting result.
And, first of all,
let me tell you
that the equivalent
title is also
just something like vertex
connectivity in almost
linear time.
Because we know
that max-flow can
be solved in almost linear time
by the breakthrough result.
So let me first
start by defining
what the [INAUDIBLE]
vertex connectivity.
Basically, I give you a
graph, undirected graph,
with n nodes and n edges.
I want to compute the
minimum number of vertices
such that, when I remove,
I disconnect the graph.
For example, in this
particular graph,
the vertex connectivity is two
because I can remove these two
node to disconnect the graph,
but I cannot remove only
a single node to
disconnect the graph.
And I would like to also mention
a very related problem called
the st-vertex mincut.
So, in addition, you are
given also two nodes, s and t.
And then, the goal is
to compute kappa s, t,
which is the minimum
number of vertices whose
removal disconnects s and t.
So how this is a problem
related to the original problem?
I will tell you in a second.
But let me explain that
this s, t vertex mincut
problem is very important.
So one important fact is
that computing this number
can be computed by a max-flow.
You can run by the
max-flow algorithm
to compute this number.
This follow because of the
max-flow min-cut theorem,
saying that maximum
number vertex disjoint s,
t path is the same as the
minimum cut separating s and t.
So, in this example,
for example,
here the minimum
vertex cut is two,
but the maximum flow, the
vertex capacitated, is also two.
And one simple observation
is that you can--
vertex connectivity,
you can compute
by just minimum of all
pair possible s and t
and then compute max-flow.
So, basically, you can
compute the connectivity
by running all pair max-flow.
So that's one simple algorithm.
Then, let me give you a very
quick survey of what is known.
So this problem is a very
well-studied problem.
So it has a really long history.
And the earliest algorithm
is done by n square cores
of maximum flow time.
And there are a lot
of work that are
trying to reduce number of
cores of the number of flows.
And the result by
Becker et al in '82,
they managed to reduce
to n cores of max-flow
to solve this vertex
connectivity problem.
And the state of
the art algorithm
is either by linear
lower regression,
or by using algebraic technique,
or using a preflow algorithm
by Henzinger and Rao and Gabow.
And one of the central
question in this area
is that whether or
not we can solve
this problem in linear time.
And this has been conjectured
by Aho, Hopcrof, and Ullman
very long ago in 1974.
And we only know
the recent progress
for small connectivity.
We know how to do
that in linear time
when connectivity is very small.
And what is the main point?
The main result of this
work is, basically, we
can solve this problem using
instead of n causal max-flow,
we can solve in
poly-logarithmic max-flow.
And using the
recent breakthrough
of max-flow algorithm, we
can solve the whole problem
in almost linear time.
And I just want to
highlight the fact
that the tools that
we use that are
different from the previous work
are based on something called
a local computation and
also sublinear algorithm
that we use.
And I just want to
highlight some techniques
that we use here include
isolating cut lemma, sublinear
time kernelization, some
sketching, and sparse recovery.
So we use a lot of modern
tools to solve this problem.
But one thing that I
would like to highlight
on what is the main difference
from this approach compared
to the previous approach
is the following,
that in the previous approach,
they try to give you a graph,
and then they try to generate
many instances of max-flow.
And each instance
has size linear m.
So the total size
of max-flow instance
would be something like the
number of core max-flow times
m.
And then, the goal
was to minimize
the number of core max-flow.
And the best known you
can do is just linear.
But what we do here
differently is the following.
That instead of generating
a max-flow of size m,
we generate many, many max-flow
instance of smaller size.
So, in particular, each of these
instances can be sublinear.
But the goal here,
we are not trying
to minimize the number
of cores, but we
minimize the size-- total size
of the max-flow instances.
So instead of you get--
we just generate
smaller instances such
that the total instance
is still a overall when
you sum total is still linear.
And, in particular,
each instance
can be sublinear in size.
And that would be what I want
to highlight, the main result.
And this is not the end
of this field in the sense
that there are some also
exciting open problems.
Namely, can you
do deterministic.
So the previous optimal
require randomness.
So the main open
question is that can you
do randomized
algorithm, can you find
an algorithm that
solves the connectivity
without a randomization?
Can you solve the weighted
version of vertex connectivity?
So there are a lot of open
problems to be solved.
Thank you.
I will stop here.
[APPLAUSE]
NIKHIL SRIVASTAVA:
Thanks a lot, Sorrachai.
We have time for
one question maybe.
OK, well, so thank you.
So we now have three
speakers from the logic and--